the Joe Rogan experience I think 55 is
an amazing weight class right now we
argue on Fox that they think they try to
get under my skin and say light weight
as the best division said don't play
with me after a beep yeah Abby was
Abby's I haven't watched many of his
fights
I watched him I said I need to go back
to my home my man he fights like it
every time
yeah he's a monster you see the michael
johnson fight he's talented
I must be jump give up smashing alone
his wrestling and his his his
ground-and-pound is just so ferocious
it's just on such another level and when
he gets a hold of guys he's getting a
hold of guys that are really good and
just ragdoll on them like what he did to
RDA did you ever see that fight yeah all
right so yeah I haven't seen those
fights I gotta go back and look
rag-dolled RDS you know just beats the
[ __ ] out of people get you to the ground
how's the big fan he something special
dude he's something special and the fact
that he did that to barboza
he wants to move up 72 she no he don't
okay metabolic meals [ __ ] out sitting
see my man hubby by the pack nutrition
is anybody out there
I'm picking up the tab psycho has down
there 55 I'm not trying to see no Kobe
right now yeah he's making 55 easy now
though so who knows I think what I
believe is gonna happen is I think
Connors gonna vacate I think they're
gonna strip him cuz Connor was got a
hundred million dollars in the bank yeah
I think he's having fun and talking [ __ ]
he's gonna keep training and he's gonna
make a big fight in the future yeah but
I think babe versus Tony is the big
fight and [ __ ] they might even do that
one in Russia they do that one to talk
about doing those big fight in Russia or
that yeah if that happens well that's a
good fight I mean everybody's been
waiting to see that fight [ __ ] yeah
that's like Tony Ferguson very
unorthodox how many wins he's got like
nine ten in a row yeah he has the most
ever in the lightweight division and I
think it's at ten I think when he beat
Kevin it was at ten who do you lose ooh
Michael Johnson he lost
- boy you gotta go wait a long time yeah
maybe it was Michael yeah yeah I mean
Tony so unorthodox and all the closer to
get Steve to our corner even if I yeah
the closer to see but man yeah he just
nobody has told Tony that what he's
doing is not who's Jaime Tony he's lost
- Jaime Tony earlier in his career it
was cruel but what is that from national
find liance interesting hey hi tried the
Hyatt Regency Oh careened our bid Ian
that guy's a very good [ __ ]
submission artist interesting yeah well
he nollette 90-mile focus have is his
name ah punch choke choke choke choke
choke yep
and running running over guys to the
Edson Barboza fight was [ __ ]
fantastic that was a fantastic if I - oh
yeah and that's the danger about about
Tony he don't really matter if he's
losing that fight
yeah first the first second round he
keeps it together yeah yeah
he's a man that dos Anjos fight was
amazing to beat the [ __ ] out of San Jose
that's it I mean he's a bad man Tony
Ferguson
you cannot sleep on Tony Ferguson I used
to fight is amazing I used to be like
man this dude striking don't look like
is something that should frighten you
too much but when it's coming so often
it's so weird angles and then he's going
for shots and he he does the exact
opposite of what you think you should do
in grappling and then he's in the
position and then we get there now he's
got like five or six moves from that
position so he's like swishing it here
and there and they're pretty know you're
shy chucked out yeah he's he's special
he's a real deal that's a that's an
amazing fight I love that fight
[Applause]